now the health of North Korea's dictator
and the control of that country's
nuclear weapons is in serious question
this morning Kim jong-un did not appear
at a major public celebration last week
now there is a report unconfirmed by CBS
News that he had heart surgery and may
be fighting for his life Raimi and
Ascencio joins us from Toki Tokyo Remy
what do we know for sure at this point
good question good morning there yeah
frankly the world doesn't know whether
Kim jong-un is alive sick or dead after
those initial reports but one thing is
for certain looking ahead that any kind
of news that comes out of North Korea
needs to be taken with a massive dose of
salt one North Korea expert told me that
it could be days maybe even longer to
know any kind of truth out of the
country this was the last time Kim
jong-un was seen in public April 11th a
meeting with his top advisors and just a
day before he reportedly underwent heart
surgery
that's according to one in South Korean
report on April 15th Kim then missed for
the first time an annual birthday event
honoring his late grandfather Kim
il-sung North Korea's founder North
Korea expert Robert Carlin says if Kim
died his successor possibly his younger
sister would need to secure a power base
before taking control of the country
you'll have fairly inexperienced North
Koreans at the top a lot of them don't
know a lot about the outside world
they're going to be factions trying to
scramble at the top but the biggest
worry if kim jonghwan died is North
Korea's estimated 30 to 40 nuclear
weapons the big sigh of relief if they
discover showing up in a few days and
China and South Korea have now refuted
those initial reports and North Korea
observers are saying that when it comes
to the health of the leader of North
Korea you really have to take everything
with a very good strong dose of
skepticism Gayle all right Thank You
Ramey you know since you're reporting
from Tokyo